diese entdeckung eines us astronomie
teams an den ringen des uranus ist
wirklich äußerst außergewöhnlich durch
eine messung der wärmestrahlung konnten
die fachleute nämlich nicht nur die
temperatur der uranus ringe feststellen
klar ist jetzt auch dass sich einer der
ringe bezüglich seiner zusammensetzung
extrem von anderen ringen im
sonnensystem unterscheidet was steckt
dahinter und wie genau gelangen diese
mysteriöse entdeckung tricks und science
fiction
die gibt's täglich faszinierendes heinz
videos abonniert den kanal nur dann
verpasst er nichts herzlich willkommen
hanus ist der erste planet der in der
neuzeit mit hilfe eines fernrohrs
entdeckt werden konnte und zwar von
william herschel im jahr 1781 von der
sonne aus gesehen ist uranus der siebte
planet sein ringsystem übrigens wurde
viel später aufgespürt und zwar zunächst
durch indirekte beobachtung wolter 2
konnte es dann später auch direkt
beobachten bislang konnten insgesamt 13
ringe des uranus entdeckt werden
dazwischen finden sich staub bender die
ringe des uranus sind nur mit wirklich
großen und leistungsstarken teleskopen
zu entdecken in der lage dazu ist
beispielsweise das atacama large
millimeter submillimeter array alma ein
internationales radioteleskop
observatorium in den nord chilenischen
anden mit hilfe von wärmebildern gelang
nun eine premiere ios forschungsteam
konnte nämlich jetzt zum ersten mal die
temperatur der uranus ringe messen diese
liegt bei 77 kelvin was ungefähr minus
196 grad celsius entspricht durch ihre
beobachtungen kamen die fachleute zu
einer weiteren spannenden erkenntnis
dazu der beteiligte forscher etwas malt
die ringe von uranus unterscheiden sich
in ihrer zusammensetzung
täglich vom saturn haupt bringt da die
albedo in optischen und infraroten
bereichen viel niedriger ist sie sind
extrem dunkel sowie kohle
sie sind im vergleich zu den ringen des
saturn auch extrem schmal
der breiteste der exelon ring ist 20 bis
100 kilometer breit der das natur und
100 oder zehntausende kilometer breiten
mit dem fachbegriff albedo bezeichnen
die experten und expertinnen das brück
strahl vermögen von objekten die selbst
nicht leuchten und somit auch in
gewisser weise ein maß für dessen
helligkeit doch die ringe des uranus
unterscheiden sich nicht nur dahingehend
von anderen bekannten ringen im
sonnensystem vor allem der sogenannte y
ring des uranus der der hellste und
dichteste von ihnen ist unterscheidet
sich enorm von anderen bekannten ringen
im sonnensystem dazu die astronomen imke
debatte die haupt ringe des saturn sind
bereit hält und bestehen aus einer
vielzahl von partikeln ganz
unterschiedlicher größe von mikrometer
großen staub im inneren behring bis zum
meter großen brocken in den haupt
trinken der hellste ringen des uranus
dagegen besteht lediglich aus brocken in
der größe eines golfballs und größer das
im haupt bringen des uranus kleine
partikel fehlen ist durchaus
ungewöhnlich diese erkenntnis lag
allerdings schon 1986 nahe als deutscher
zwei um den uranus geflogen war und
aufnahmen gemacht hatte dazu der
astronom etwas molter wir wussten
bereits dass die entweder etwas komisch
ist weil das kleinere zeug fehlt es wird
offenbar von ihr sind etwas verweht oder
ist sagt club
wir wissen es nicht dies ist aber ein
schritt um die zusammensetzung besser zu
verstehen und dadurch herauszufinden ob
das material für alle ringe aus der
gleichen quelle stamme es sind also noch
viele fragen offen vor allem also zur
entstehung der uranus ringe
möglicherweise entstanden sie als
überreste von monden die ineinander
stürzen oder aber um ehemalige
asteroiden große hoffnung setzen die
experten und experten dahingehend auf
den einsatz des james webb
weltraumteleskop das ab 2021 an den
start gehen soll
denn das riesen weltraum teleskop könnte
mit seiner auflösung die astronomie
komplett revolutionieren die liste ist
lang das was das james webb
weltraumteleskop kurz
alles ermöglichen könnte ist echt der
reine wahnsinn dass riesenteleskop ist
unter anderem jahr speziell dafür
entwickelt worden außerirdisches leben
zu suchen anders als das hubble teleskop
das im sichtbaren namen ultravioletten
und nahen infraroten spektrum sucht ist
dass sie dabei usd ein supertalent im
infraroten bereich so kann es
beispielsweise die atmosphäre von
exoplaneten analysieren die wiederum
hinweise auf planet ares leben gibt aber
nicht nur dass fachleute erwarten
unglaubliche aufnahmen und erkenntnisse
zu sternen und planeten system und so
erhoffen sich die experten nur experten
auch neue erkenntnisse zu dem
mysteriösen oranges ring und noch etwas
größeres plant der größte versender
weltweit amazon plant riesige weltraum
kolonie fake gravitation durch rotation
anklicken das video anschauen und
abonnieren nämlich breaking lab hammer
kanal mit coolen videos bis dann bleibt
dran